reject nation Arrested Development it's
coming back in like a month or something
I had just heard the news about this
actually on an episode of screen junkies
news and then today they dropped a
trailer already number one on trending
good for these guys figured it's it be
appropriate to wear Marvel related
shirts now that Arrested Development is
possibly connected to the MCU Easter Egg
[Music]
[Music]
maybe we can figure out where it all
went wrong
huge mistake
[Music]
it seems a lot has changed over the
years everyone back together in town
this time but this actually new
beginning finally getting the award they
think they deserve doesn't seem like
would get the votes because nothing
holds you down oh wow
less than a May 29th that's like right
around the corner people I'm not gonna
BS you guys I have seen every episode of
Arrested Development it's been such a
while and I've seen so many shows that I
kind of don't remember a lot of what
happens in Arrested Development and
especially that last season which was
really mixed on how people received it I
actually heard there they'd recut it I
heard the creator of the show or
something
recut it so that way it doesn't have
these weird sort of singular focus
episodes of each character that gets me
excited cuz I wasn't a fan of that style
to help myself out with keeping up with
the show and watching this new season
I'm gonna rewatch all the season for all
15 of those episodes because the recut
sounds really appealing to me and with
that in mind I heard that they're gonna
be going back to telling this show in
the style of how they did seasons 1
through 3 so that gives more hope what's
really cool about the footage that
they're giving us they're showing
they're all back they're all gonna share
screen time I know with the last season
they had to sort of shoot it that way
and edit it the episodes that way
because of how busy each one of the
actors schedules was they had to shoot
it in a complex fashion I feel like what
this trailer was really just trying to
show you is that don't worry guys
they're all gonna be sharing screen time
together this time around further where
these actors were a few years ago when
they did season 4 their schedules were a
lot crazier a lot of these guys have
either some of them have gotten busier
and some of their careers have slowed
down a bit so with that in mind I
imagine is probably easier for them to
get them all together they don't really
tell you a hell of a lot of what's going
on in this season but for the first time
it seems like Michael you know Jason
Bateman I actually have moments of
happiness like sure there was the funny
part where he's like let's get the hell
out of here there were moments where it
seemed like he was genuinely bonding
with his dysfunctional family and with a
fan base as hardcore as the Arrested
Development fanbase I'm sure the writers
of this season knew what the feedback
was off the season for revival I'm sure
they're gonna give it their best I have
a lot of faith that these guys are gonna
give it their all and probably deliver a
great season I have a lot of faith in
that anyway guys you're excited Arrested
Development is coming back can't wait to
refresh my memory on all the adventures
because it's been a long time kind of
forgot a hell of a lot especially season
four gonna watch that recut anywho you
guys can subscribe to the reject nation
click that notification really get
notified every time one of our vids is
up you can check us on patreon
full-length TV show reactions weekly Q&A
is would love to have you become a
patron I checked today